now the numbers are in for ccsd drug use
on campus this just a month after a
student at seaway middle school died
from an overdose on pills laced with
fentanyl
madison kimbrough joins us in the
newsroom to break down those numbers
madison sally this data from ccsd dates
from august 2021 to march of this year
and it shows that school police have
responded to nearly 1400 calls regarding
illegal drug use this school year now
here is the chart where you can see the
numbers and it shows that in the
2019-2020 school year drug use was even
higher while the school year isn't over
just yet you can see in the graphic
coming up that marijuana is the primary
drug of choice with alcohol coming in
second and tobacco and nicotine as third
when we reached out to ccsd it was
unclear what drugs were considered other
but we're told that if it's not on the
list then it falls into that category
repeat offenders were also mentioned as
you will see here in the second column
of this list faith harper a former ccsd
safe school professional and now a youth
counselor at the community counseling
center says over the years she has seen
it increase substantially within the
younger generation
some of the kids that i interview when i
do assessments they've been starting
using drugs like
nine years old eight years old you know
when i ask them the first time they've
ever tried something it's usually very
young it just seems like it's getting
worse and worse the age is getting lower
and lower where people are being exposed
or trying things
mary more and more parents and students
have been vocal about drug use on campus
specifically at ccsd board meetings now
other listed drugs on the list from ccsd
included hallucinogens inhalants with
crack cocaine and amphetamines being the
lowest amount reported on the list and
that not coded category means the drug
was not identified in the newsroom
madison kimbrough live local now